[موسيقى]
بطل خارق للعاده يحمل مطرقه ولا يغطي راسه
هكذا تبدو صورتك كريس سامسونج في اذان
جماهيره بعد ان اصبح نجما ذا شهره وسعه في
فضاء هوليود ومن اكثرهم اجورا لكن هذا
النجاح لم ياتي بسهوله فقد تخطى العديد من
العقبات ليكون حيث هو اليوم فما قصته ولد
الممثل الاسترالي كريستوفر همس عام
1983 في ملبورن لعائله من الطبقه المتوسطه
فوالده مدرس ووالدته مستشاره بالخدمه
الاجتماعيه
قبل ان يبدا مسيرته كممثل عروضا تلفزيونيه
بين عامي 2001 و 2002
ظهر في مسلسل الاطفال اذا صعد
وبالمسلسل الخيالي جونز
وبمسلسل الكوميديا ما شاء الله حتى لاحظ
الفرصه له في عام 2004 وخضع لتجربه اداء
لدور روب هانتر في المسلسل الاسترالي هم
اند اوي
لكنه لم يكن اهلا للدور ما جعل الحلم
يتاجل لولا ان القائمين على المسلسل راو
ان بامكانه القيام بدورهيد هو رغم انه بقي
يؤذي هذا الدور حتى عام 2007 الا انه لم
يلبث طموحه كما انه مشاركته خلال تلك
الفتره بنسخه الاسريه من دانسينج وات ذا
ستارز لم تمنحه الشعبيه الكافيه عندما
اصبح خامسه متسابقا يتم اقصاء في عام 2009
كان كريس قد نجح اخيرا في اقتحام هوليود
من خلال فيلم الخيال العلميك وفي العام
نفسه
ظهر في فيلم طب بيرفكت جتا واي ولكنه ايضا
لم يحظى بالجماهير الكافيه لم يياس الممثل
الاسترالي من محاولاته العديده حتى ضرب
موعدا مع بدايه الشهره في عام 2011 عندما
عرض عليه دور البطل الخارق في فيلم ثور
ضمن سلسله افلام مارفل سينما تك يو نيفرس
طلب الدور من كريس ان يكتسب وزنا ولم
يتردد حينها في زياده وزنه حوالي تسعه
كيلو جرامات وبالفعل نجح الفيلم بتقديمه
جماهريه
اعاده النجم الصاعد تمثيل الشخصيه في
سلسله افلام الابطال الخارقين خلال
السنوات اللاحقه وهو ما جعل اسمه يرتبط
بالبطل الخيالي ثور وبفضل هذا الدور حجز
مكانه مميزه في هوليود
قدمت راس العديد من الافلام والمسلسلات
التلفزيونيه والمسلسلات على شبكه الانترنت
التي كان من ابرزها ذكابا ان داوود ردان
سنو وايت
ذهنتس مان وراش وهو ما اهله لنيل العديد
من الجوائز الفنيه كجائزه بافته وجائزه
تين تشويس وجائزه بيبول
فقد قدم اكثر من 41 عملا قبل ان يصل لقلوب
الجماهير ويصبح احد الفنانين الاعلى اجرا
في العالم مع ثروه تقدر ب 130 مليون دولار
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]